I am Harrison I work at welcome
specifically the Wellcome collection the
difference between the Wellcome
collection and the Wellcome Trust is one
that you might already know hands up
anyone who's been to welcome collection
yeah good few everyone else come along
there's a few stops away on the Circle
Line we're up by Euston this is the
outside of the building this is the
inside of the building it's all very
open and friendly and nice we have lots
of interactive activities the the famous
Reading Room there and we also have a
lot of more traditional gallery spaces
and experts who can tell you all sorts
of interesting things about the history
of health and how that has been
expressed through art and kind of
typical museum collections through
history yeah we have this kind of stuff
upstairs and then downstairs hidden away
underneath Houston the Stax rare books
that are not out there for people to
grab off the shelves that are
requestable and we also have
photographers who like to push trolleys
around and pretend that their catalogue
is all of this stuff is being digitized
progressively quite fast actually we are
working with the Internet Archive who
are producing around 10,000 images a
date of this material it's a lot of
images it's a basically too many images
for our catalogers to get through 10,000
images a day or kind of 350,000 a month
is way too many for the catalogs that we
have to produce detailed catalog
descriptions for all of those works but
when they are digitized when they are
cataloged they end up on the website if
you click up at the top there on the
collections page you can go here and you
can search for books and pictures if you
search for something like cat you might
get a result like this this is a cat
preparing for surgery these are some
much happier cats
searching for horse gives you here so
like this the projection it's not
fantastic but I think you can still make
out welcome is a very weird Museum
collection it's it's stranger than most
it some of you might have already
spotted the weird thing here this horse
has two human feet I have no idea why it
doesn't explain why in the castle of
description why this kind of sense or I
don't know it's definitely the worst of
all the types of half-man half-horse
like how it runs I don't know yeah but
nowhere in this castle of description
does it say that this horse has two
human feet and that's the point that
we'll come back to again and again
through this talk we also have lots of
pictures of skeletons so many skeletons
I've learned so much over the last year
about different depictions of death
through the the ages unexpected domain
for avid scientist VM we also have loads
of text a lot of the things that we're
digging are books and when you
photograph a book or a page of a book
there's a lot of text on there that you
can OCR turn into tests we have books
about gelatin cookery if you've ever
wondered about how people used to cook
with gelatin we're the place to come
apparently which Thor Eve as well we've
got plenty of those so we have all of
our images we have all of our text and
here in the middle we have images with
lots of lovely metadata over on the the
pure fixed side we have all of our
catalog descriptions and pure text
records like archives that don't have
any visual material associated with them
this starts to present a problem some of
you might have already intuited what
that problem is it's that stuff over on
the left the images that have no text
associated with them because image
search when you type a bunch of words
into that search box doesn't search for
images it's a lie we've all been
convinced of this live by Google and how
fantastically close that system is how
it just works the image search does not
search for images image search searches
for text about images when you type in
that search box the search algorithm
doesn't go and look at the images
themselves it goes and checks whether
the words that appear in your query
match the words in the captions or the
descriptions of those images so all of
that stuff over on the left-hand side we
can't get access to to the algorithm
they are invisible if they have no text
associated with them we can't see them
we can't connect researchers to those
corners of the collection coming back to
this guy when I put together this
presentation and I want to find this
image I can't find it by typing out a
horse for two human feet I have to type
a horse with a long mane standing in
front of a battle which is weird is it's
not what I'm looking for it's not the
interesting thing to me about that image
so when I arrived at welcome I thought
there's a pretty obvious solution to
this problem we surgically modify our
catalogers so that they can type at a
million words per minute and we just
catalog everything to the like complete
exhaustive extent that we need but you
know it's welcome they fund a lot of
medical research and apparently medical
ethics is a thing so that's off the
table so we turned to computer vision
instead we're going to kind of deviate a
little bit into image feature embeddings
word embedding it's that kind of thing
descriptions of how they all work now
and then hopefully emerge in a bit to
explain how this is a these are the
components of a solution to this problem
so image feature embeddings
this is a kind of hand wavy working
description of what image feature
embeddings are but they're kind of like
the DNA of an image you have for a
particular image an array of numbers
that express certain features about what
are
the content of an image so for an image
of a dog like this you would produce an
array of numbers using a neural network
standard off-the-shelf thing like Fuji G
or a resinate and for an image like a
dog you would expect to see high
activations and the features that
express things like fur or grass or ears
or eyes or paws and you would expect to
see similar activations for an image
like this of a cat
it also has fur it also has eyes it also
has grass and paws for a different image
like an image of car we expect to see
different levels of activations indexes
of that array you can think of these
feature vectors as positions or
coordinates in a high dimensional space
so our dog image would be positioned
here in the complete space of all
possible feature embeddings our cat
might be nearby because it has similar
features but our car would be somewhere
completely different because of those
different features word embeddings do
very very similar things but for words
so they they try to capture the way that
words are used or tokens are used in
natural language the kind of context
that they appear in and the semantic
meaning of those words based on what's
around them so similarly for dog we
would expect it to be quite close to cat
and car to be somewhere else because
they use in different contexts they have
different meanings so we have our
ingredients for a solution to this
problem we have our image feature vector
space our word feature vector space but
they are very very different spaces they
are they are produced using totally
different methods
they have totally different
dimensionalities and in theory it's very
very hard to connect the two there's
this thing that is referred to very
often called the semantic gap that
refers to the fact that these are
different spaces and they encode
different things bridging the semantic
gap is supposedly a very hard thing to
do
but it's kind of not
unintuitive Lee or in refutation of the
literature we have a lot of examples out
there of datasets that connect language
and images and if you think about what
these feature vectors are they're just
arrays they're just embedding layers and
that's all but neural networks really do
is they connect different dimensionality
feature spaces together
so using these examples of an image and
a word we can extract the feature vector
for the image and position it somewhere
in future space lookup using a standard
library of word vectors like glove or
fast text or word of it look up the word
vector for dog and we can connect with
it
we can do the same thing with cat and we
can do the same thing with car and we
can do this again and again and again
for thousands of different examples of
thousands of a class of image and word
and eventually learn a mapping that
connects image feature vector space to
word vector space and once we've done
that we can take a new image extract a
feature vector for it even if it's
within a class that we have never seen
before and we can predict where in
feature vector space it's going to be
wearing word vector space sewing is
going to plausibly turn up and we can
make some kind of inference about what
the kind of work that describes that
image is gonna be that's how image
captioning works that's how
classifiers work image classifiers you
just add a soft max layer to that and
that's your classifier but we can also
go the other way around we can take a
new word that we've never seen visual
examples of before and map back into
image feature vector space and that's
basically image search you take a word
that you've never seen before and you
try to match it to some visual material
return the nearest neighbors to that
position that you're guessing the right
kind of material it's going to be in and
it works magic this is a technique that
was proposed in a paper in 2012 that
came out of Google called device for
deep visual semantic embeddings and it's
kind of flown under the radar for a long
time but it's a really powerful
technique and it does work at this point
though there is quite an obvious
question what happens if the user gives
you a query with more than one word how
do you encode a more complicated
situation than things that fit within
the standard word vector libraries that
we know and love and the solution is one
that has popped up in the last year or
two sentence embedding they've been
getting a lot of attention models like
Burt and info cent and gptt have been
getting all sorts of attention because
they solve this problem they do roughly
the same thing as image feature vectors
and word vectors for a sentence like the
cat sat on the mat we would expect to
see similar activations or similar
levels of activation in similar features
to a kitten on a rug even though none of
the words are shared between the two
they have similar meanings we would
expect to see them in similar positions
in future space
and a different sentence like this film
is bad should appear in a different
region in speak of feature space and
that's what we see with models like Bert
and in presenting we have the cat on the
map and the kitten on the road quite
close together and the film being bad in
a different region of space like I said
there is big models out there called
Bert and they are very popular I'm gonna
say some bad things about Bert which is
why this gif is here we are using not
Bert
partly because when we were doing this
work Bert haven't been released and the
current state of the art at that time
was info sent which is a model that was
put out by Facebook info sent also
allows us to get over some of the
problems that we have with Bert the
principal one being that censors
embedding models are pretty bad encoding
very short sequences so while they
perform fantastically with a set of
tokens that is five or six tokens long
and they can encode all of that semantic
complexity if you give them a sequence
that is one or two words long they
really struggle to add any kind of
valuable meaning to that they can't
perform the same function as word
vectors so we want to produce some kind
of sentence embedding model that retains
the complexity of the long sentences but
also encodes the same amount of
complexity for short sequences the way
that in percent is trained allowed us to
do that we made a small modification to
the input data retrained in percent or
continued training in percent based on
the model that had been open sourced and
it worked and we can now show you some
results so again the model or the
results that you're gonna see here are
based on absolutely no text whatsoever
computer simulations of proteins and
other molecules again the screen is
really bad here so you can't really see
this but these are and the model has no
access to any text about these images is
purely looking at them and returning
results based on its understanding of
language and its understanding of how
that language maps onto visual features
text written in Hindi I don't know
whether any of this is Hindi but it's a
pretty good guess
yeah photograph of stone arches in a
church it's not bad
MRI scans of brains some of these
definitely aren't but some of them
definitely are really horrible
disgusting drawings of skin diseases as
I said at the beginning this the
Wellcome collection is a medical Museum
so we have a lot of really grim stuff
avert your eyes if you don't want to see
this because it does work
ready moving on
pretty drawings of plants and flowers as
some I bleach again it works we have
tons of botanical stuff as well as the
horrible things
astronomical charts of the Moon pretty
good surgical instruments bang on
intricate drawings of skulls not bad
collection of blood cells I can
understand where it's coming from
I can't preparing for surgery we've got
our old friend right up at the top there
an old wooden boat pretty decent and my
favorite of all of these results
skeletons in excessively dramatic poses
I don't know why this is a thing it's
bizarre we have so many of them I don't
understand why if you're learning about
Anatomy you have to have so much drama
involved but it's a thing yeah we have
tons of these come and see them they're
a lot of fun so there is a caveat to all
of this when we were developing this I
did a lot of this development I got the
model to that stage that you just saw
and was very happy with it
I had standards queries that I would put
into this model
I could see whether it is returning good
results I was assessing her against
standard academic data sets and
calculating metrics based on all of that
doing all the good things but we then
rolled it out to a wider set of internal
stakeholders basically we showed it to
the catalogers who were eventually gonna
be using this tool and while I had done
some early testing of feeding it absurd
scenarios like this cows on the beach
you don't expect to see pictures of cows
on the beach I know that we don't have
any lectures have cows on the beach in
the collection but I wanted to see what
it was gonna return it doesn't return
cows on the beach but it does return
hippos in rivers which is like fair it's
it's not the right result but it's you
can see what it's getting at but we're
edging closer and closer and closer to a
kind of google gorillas situation here
which is not somewhere we want to end up
and like I said we rolled this out to
catalogers we produced a little demo for
them that they could interact with and
one of the queries that they input to
this model was birthday cake which seems
very very innocuous like you really
expect anything other than birthday cake
to come back as this as the results to
this query but I think that I hadn't
accounted for at the time was how
tightly clustered all of the food words
in word vector space are I'm gonna
listen for
people to like giggle or gasp but as you
get where this is going so we have very
very tightly clustered food words in
word vector space so the word for cake
or the feature vector for cake and the
feature vector for meat very very
similar the Machine has trouble
distinguishing between the two because
in natural language they used in very
similar contexts but the machine then
carries over that back close association
or misunderstanding into the visual
world and also has trouble
distinguishing between perfectly
beautiful steaks and horrendous pictures
of surgery so the the results that
people were getting back for searching
for birthday cake were things that look
like that but unpick selected not a
thing that you want to do to your users
in the real world so that's a brief
caveat I am gonna leave off all of the
the kind of heavy stuff and
recommendations because we've already
had a fantastic day of very serious
talked about how to address these kind
of things I'm gonna leave it light here
and just say thank you
also hiring if any of this sounds fun to
you if you want to build the
infrastructure that powers this and
hopefully a good version of this and
also lots of other fun models and you
know a bit of scarlet come and talk to
us Thanks do we have any questions
so relating images and text obviously
goes two ways in one direction you're
trying to get a caption and the other
your pointers and search for an image
yeah I can see how in the captioning
case it would make more sense to use the
sort of sentence embedding based model
because you're trying to generate
something more like natural language
yeah
but going the other way often people
search queries are actually quite
they're just sort of fragments they
might just be a few key words yeah had
you considered or did you try rather
than using sentence and beddings in that
way just using the sort of centroid for
example some sort of weighted average of
the word of beddings or people's search
queries yes we did try that and it's a
much simpler solution it doesn't work
quite as well as this model that we have
produced to capture the complexity of
longer queries especially on those
longer queries where people are really
adding context but yet the majority of
queries that we get are single word and
then the majority after that are two
words that are usually nouns so yeah in
the majority of cases that is a much
simpler solution do this kind of thing
thank you no worries
it's two questions basically one is very
simple
can you find the horse no you can get a
lot of other horses but I'm just with
feet no sadly not they're not not we dig
enough feet at least with my second
question clearly the image classifier is
based on a very broad yes dataset
whereas the Wellcome collection which
I'm familiar with as you say is for a
lot of brilliant gruesome images and
dancing skeletons is it possible to tag
and partially retrain the image
classifier but it's a bit more skewed
into a welcome direction yes so we did
the initial word based thing is trained
purely on image net then the thing with
sentence embeddings we start to add in
microsoft coco the image captioning
they'd set and then once that model is
working well it's robust it's performing
well on all the matrix we do a bit of
transfer learning to add it into well to
just slide it over to the welcome domain
it does quite well with the variant so I
hope you agree but yeah the variety of
stuff that we have in the collection is
so broad luckily we do have a lot of
stuff that is captioned well that does
have yet works that are well titled so
there is enough material to do a bit of
that transfer learning all of the
examples are produced from a held outset
so know where we're fitting going on
there I hope but yeah we do do a bit of
that transport learning
so I'm not sure how they welcome they
say is well and do you have any problems
dealing with the change in language over
time as well if the meanings of words
can change so does that affect anything
not in this particular example but it is
a thing that we deal with quite
regularly in other problems and other
datasets yeah it's a huge spelling the
before a spelling unified it was just
chaos no one knew how to spell anything
and trying to apply were directors to
that kind of thing it's just very close
to impossible
yeah it's an interesting problem and not
much work is being done on it sorry one
more question please it's the one in the
middle
I was really interesting thank you um I
was wondering basically what you were
going to do next when you mentioned
about how you were going to be using at
all with the catalogs I'm just intrigued
about yeah so because of the the kind of
unexpected nature of some of the results
that you get back I don't think it's
it's ready to be swapped out for the
standard elasticsearch thing that we
have going on the the front end we're
not going to be rolling out out to the
public but it is a really useful or we
think it's very promising as a tool for
catalogers internally to get started on
cataloging that material if you can
constrain that date set so that you're
not just even with the chaos of the
entire collection and just catalog the
horses so you are a horse domain expert
and you know all of the things that
should be annotated on a record about
horses you can deal with all of them in
one go that kind of approach has been
really useful in other domains
particularly text so doing that with
visual material seems promising as well
alright that's all for question time
Thank You Harrison one more round of
applause for Harrison please
[Applause]